[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hey my name is katie and i'm a tasty  producer here with some tips on this  recipe so first of all these take a bit  of time to prepare what takes the  longest time is the infinity stone  itself you'll be drying it out for two  to three days so you want to factor that  in if you're going to have a party it's  going to take you about four days for  these to be ready but i'm telling you  they are worth it they look so cool  and how you'll know they're done in the  two to three days is the outside will be  entirely hard to the touch but the  inside will still be gooey my last tip  is just like add some extra wow factor i  like to use a golden cupcake liner like  the golden gauntlet where all the  infinity stones go in but you can do  whatever you want so play with it have  fun uh make them show us pictures put  them in the comments and i hope you guys  make some beautiful cupcakes  oh yes  [Music]  [Music]  you